virginia la jr smith viven en arizona y
se emocionaron cuando donald trump
anunció un mitin de regreso a una zona
cercana acudieron para apoyar a su líder
al que consideran ultrajado
y
votado por trump las dos veces y sabemos
que ganó esta última vez tenemos que
decir lo que es verdad recuerdas lo que
le hicieron a jesús por decir la verdad
lo crucificaron lo mismo que le hicieron
a donald trump trataron de justificarlo
no en una cruz sino por lo que
representa pero borges transforma el
mito de unas elecciones robadas sigue
vivo para muchos republicanos y donald
trump dedicó gran parte de su discurso a
negar su derrota ante joe biden hace 15
meses una persona que viene y tiene
multitudes que van más allá de lo que
cualquier ojo puede ver no hay nadie que
pueda ver el final de esta multitud ese
no es alguien que perdió una elección y
ahora a causa de eso nuestro país está
haciendo destruidos redes 20 se rompió a
sus seguidores que ayudan a los
republicanos al menos a los que a él le
agradan a recuperar el control del
congreso en las elecciones de mitad de
período en noviembre
necesita volver necesita reunirnos como
país prometió que iba a hacer 2 grande
de nuevo lo hizo antes lo va a hacer de
nuevo en la campaña electoral de 2022
comienza en un momento en el que el
presidente joe biden es impopular en
temas como la inflación que alcanzó el
7% en el último año cuesta el doble
llenar mi camión de gasolina cuesta el
doble llenar mi auto con las compras la
leche el tocino todo es más caro si
quieres remodelar tu casa es más caro
eso es un resultado directo de joe biden
desordenando la cadena de suministro
donald trump ha dejado muy claro que no
va a desaparecer del espectro político
en 2022 está buscando ser de gran
influencia para el partido republicano y
en 2024 los seguidores aquí lo esperan
tron buscará una restauración